[Musique]
émilie nicolas christian dufour
sébastien bovet bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
alors hier soir on imagine que eu des
coups de fil entre québec et ottawa
québec et montréal
avec le ton un peu courroucé
j'explique tout début d'émission germain
vite vite en contexte et que le québec a
donné de l'argent au spvm qui à la ville
de montréal les enveloppes dédiées pour
le spvm pour faire face aux tueries que
c'était un bon depuis un certain temps
et le québec dit avant d'en rajouter on
veut être sûr que quand donne l'argent
la ville ne se retire pas
par ailleurs de l'argent qu'elle devait
mettre de sorte qu'ils aient encore
moins d'argent pour la police je peux
entendre madame plantes que réagi là
dessus puis je reviens ensuite
notre gestion elle est irréprochable
mais qu'on se laissera pas on est ce
rapport personnes attaquées notre
intégrité l'intégrité de notre
administration mais également
l'intégrité de l'institution qu'est la
ville de montréal
plu à sébastien je commence avec vous
aviez l'argent qui est carré pour l'espé
vn vo spvm puis nous on en a l'air pas
que c'est un rapport hélas la ministre
la sécurité publique vient de tweeté une
photo tout va bien en panne à mme plante
et et elle et on discute pas ce qui n
annoncent qu est ce que vous comprenez
sébastien de la séquence convient de
ville depuis hier je comprends qu'elle
quelqu'un qui dit quelque chose qu'il
n'aurait pas dû dire dans les
conversations qu'ils ont eues avec des
journalistes iem jeu je comprends pas
pourquoi quelqu'un quelque part a laissé
entendre que il y avait des questions
très incisive qui était posé sur la
façon dont l'argent a été dépensé à
montréal et s'il n'y avait pas eu un des
financements de la police parce que là
on est entré dans une vrille qui a
empoisonné la discussion en tout cas
l'église les dernières heures de la
discussion entre montréal et québec moi
hier on me disait oui on aimerait un peu
plus de reddition de comptes mais on va
passer à autre chose parce que ce qui
importe c'est de trouver une solution
pic de débloquer de l'argent pour la
ville de montréal là dedans il ya deux
deux partenaires et demi à la ville de
montréal et le gouvernement du québec
paie peut-être le syndicat en périphérie
qui dans ces trois acteurs là a pu
laisser entendre une chose comme celle
là et pourquoi c'est la question que je
me pose aussi il n'ya pas j'arrive pas
trouvé de réponse patrice parce que
c'est apporter un climat toxique dans la
négociation dans la discussion emilie
christian c'est comme s'il y avait des
gens en gouvernance québec clients qui
ont encore une méfiance à tort ou à
raison envers l'attitude de la mairesse
son attitude vis-à-vis les policiers
christian
oui c'est clair qu'on aurait pensé que
ça faisait la sphère du gouvernement
legault dans un dossier qui inquiète
tout le monde à l'autre d'une campagne
électorale de braquer les projecteurs
sur
l'administration plantes mais la
jeunesse marivin tremblay ce midi en
huitièmes il faut disait que c'est comme
une erreur que le gouvernement voulait
pas que ça sorte pas moi mais moi comme
citoyen je m'embarquais dans la guerre
de chiffres d'orange raison ou pas mais
moi ce samedi plaît pas je suis moins
négatif figure que beaucoup de gens là
bas parce que ça attire l'attention sur
le fait qu'elle a en un gros problème
faut pas que ça dégénère une ou deux
volets en ce qui a trait à la violence
criminelle à montréal quand même des
gens qui sont tirés sur des terrasses
services et de dire que le volet
prévention qui est très important que le
volet répression ça attire l'attention
sur le fait que madame plantes au
pengrowth crédibilité en ce qui a trait
à la répression qui est nécessaire
actuellement ce sont une réalité le pote
bonne image à actionnement bon peut-être
que le réseau sur les chiffres peut-être
que c'est mais reste que c'est pas
mauvais qu il ya un message qui est
envoyé à madame plantes dont la
conférence de presse cette semaine n'ont
pas été très très impressionnante examen
d'un plan de paix sérieux le tunnel on
n'est pas dans la répression par la
prévention avant tout qui est nécessaire
par d'autres contextes on est dans la
répression qu'il faut que vous vous
donner une crédibilité sur ce volet là
lorsqu'il est très s'attaquer entre
autres par la fraternité des policiers
puis elle a un déficit de crédibilité
côte est a troqué lequel les cheveux
parce qu emilie elle a effectivement
jongler pas elle mais je son parti à
jongler avec ce concept de des finances
et la police concept qui north america
enfin plus que north america mais
essentiellement nord-américain de
groupes très à gauche qui disent ils les
policiers faut leur enlever du pouvoir
de l'argent pour amener saga donc
comment vous voyez ce qui est en train
de se passer mais lincoln
c'est intéressant parce que d'un côté il
ya peut-être des gens qui trouvent qu'un
projet montréal était trop proche de ses
idées là mais c'est sûr que pour les
gens qui posent pour les financements de
la police
je ne vois pas qui l'a d'envoi projet
montréal comme comme comme un allié puis
je pense que là la sortie de valérie
plantes aujourd'hui sur cette pièce sur
leurs maux en fait c'est pas nouveau que
le projet montréal et la danse depuis
qu'ils sont au pouvoir depuis déjà
quatre ans si le budget du spvm avait
diminué je pense qu'on serait donc je
pense que je pense que ce soit à ce
niveau là je pense qu'effectivement que
à l'aube d'une campagne électorale
provinciale
c'est normal lorsqu'il ya des problèmes
dans la métropole pour vouloir mettre
essentiellement la patate chaude dans la
dans la cour de quelqu'un dont on a
voulu le faire en privé on aurait voulu
utiliser d'autres m'ont peut-être mais
là c'est sorti cette façon là et je
pense pas en fait que ça soit bon même
stratégiquement d'avoir fait ça
si valérie plante était une mairesse qui
était impopulaire à montréal ça serait
autre chose mais l'ajustement avec la
réélection que quelqu'un d'avoir elle
même n'est pas si longtemps le fait de
s'attaquer à la mairesse de métropole où
il ya des citoyens qui sont un pied d'un
point de vue communication publique je
pense que personne n'a quoi que ce soit
à gagner dans le spectacle
et là ils ont quelques heures sébastien
pour régler tout ça parce que on promet
une annonce la mairesse le dit ce matin
avant le déclenchement des
déclenchements va être ensemble à 8
heures dimanche matin en ondes de rdi
donc ça veut dire que demain on doit
faire une annonce crédible concrète pour
assurer les montréalais des soit une
nouvelle escouade soit de l'argent soit
des moyens pour les policiers ou les
nouvelles sur ce front là sont bonnes
c'est à dire qu'il ya une rumeur qui
flotte sur la colline parlementaire puis
sur l'autel de vide à montréal qu il y
aurait une conférence de presse demain
pour annoncer une entente irait d'abord
donc une entendra ensuite d'une
conférence de presse à laquelle madame
planque madame guilbaud assisterez sur
les long des lignes énoncé par madame
plantes c'est à dire plus de prévention
plus d'effectifs plus d'argent au spvm
donc malgré tout malgré tout le brouhaha
d'aujourd'hui semble que les
négociations bien avancées aujourd'hui
et qu'on est tout près d'une entente est
d'une annonce qui se ferait demain parce
que comme vous le dites le gouvernement
veut pas faire cette annonce en campagne
électorale pour pas être taxé d'être
électoraliste et de se faire du capital
politique électorale sur le dos de ce
qui se passe à montréal osm oui on veut
éviter autant que possible des annonces
gouvernementales pendant la campagne
électorale quoique devant une crise
évidemment les candidats redeviennent
ministre et le candidat prince était
toujours premier ministre il va de soit
meilleur donc on a quelques heures ça ça
et des romans cette échéance là à aider
pour un dénouement pour les gens qui
veulent du concret mais encore faut-il
que ce soit bien ficelé patrice parce
que c'est bien beau ce se précipiter
mais faut que j'annonce pic l'entendre
soit bien ficelé pour que ça donne des
résultats ça aussi c'est la
démonstration qu'il doit faire mais
il me semble que paul soit le maintenant
que de bien conclure ça parce que les
citoyens leur tolérance sera nul c'était
quoi efficace là dedans mais moi je me
répète lot ou bien la campagne prend la
tête de citoyens moi je serais content
du message qui a été envoyé en mai d'un
plan tout ce qu'un message qui était
nécessaire bompas un autre chapitre
longue mais je pense que cela mérite est
il nécessaire on a besoin de plus de
répression même si c'est populaire dans
la culture dont elle est issue vous
aimez les vous dites on n'avait pas
besoin d'envoyer le message elle est
déjà aux yeux de groupes qui veulent du
des financements elle est déjà un
adversaire et les plus lents ce camp-là
assistante et qu'elle a déjà été
c'est quelque chose qui a déjà suscité
beaucoup de déception de démobilisation
d'un
projet montréal laisse les gens qui sont
dans ce cas là on peut le raid de la
mairesse depuis déjà plusieurs années
ceci dit je pense mme importante quand
on parle de prévention pour l'instant il
est beaucoup défendent à prévention qui
va au spvm même et lorsque les bébés est
de la prévention en fait la prévention
du spvm sont aussi de la surveillance
essentiellement c'est d'aller dans les
milieux nuit pour essayer de regarder ce
que les jeunes enfants avant même qu'ils
aient fait quoi que ce soit est ce si ça
ne peut pas à être compliquant la même
genre de prévention qui est souvent
demandé de la fois du point de vue des
organismes communautaires et à dire
investir dans le logement social à
investir dans la lutte contre la
pauvreté investir dans les
la vie des jeunes dans le système
scolaire dans l'ours qui en sorte que
les gens développent un sentiment
d'appartenance à leur communauté alors
société aussi la personne que j'ai vu
intervenir un pull là dessus dans les
derniers jours c'est dominique anglade
avec ce avec son annonce de dire de
l'argent qui quitte à l'ats la police à
l'opération s'en tape avec le
gouvernement du québec en donne autant
au but plus communautaire mais je pense
que souvent on mélange les choses quand
on dit qu'on aime et qu'on les laisse en
prévention si on envoyait lesbiennes
dans les écoles
ce n'est absolument pas la même chose
que d'investir en communauté mais dans
le logement social investi dans les
causes profondes et de la fille que je
cueille qui sont des choses qui ont
répété ce qu'ils vous disent rien avec
ce que vous devinez avec christian je
vous donne après que ça c'est que
il ya des gens qui militent pour qu'ils
aient un des financements pour que cet
argent là effectivement soient
transférés vers le communautaire vers
des logements avaient en fait le social
il ya des gens qui disent faisons ça
mais ne des finances n'ont pas à la
police on opposait deux des finances et
pour financer au tour de christian
il fait il faut les deux c'est clair
qu'il faut de la prévention il faut
continuer dans la prévention et pas
question de boire mais il faut se mettre
à prononcer un autre mot qui est moins
populaire dans la culture de madame
plate est issu même si elle s'est
éloigné je comprends ce que dit mimi le
meaux répression bon on est quand même
dans des fonctions régaliennes la loi et
on en est rendu là c'est ce à quoi des
citoyens s'attendent et dans la culture
politique et québécois cet actionnaire
le mot répression et comme kaboul il
faut vraiment à réprimer et déjà qu'il
faut tirer sur des terrasses sur la rue
saint denis très bien le dimanche donc 8
heures sébastien vous allez nous
indiquer carte à l'appui analyse là on
va suivre des luttes qui s'annonce quand
même intéressant des endroits où la caq
que veut faire des gains qui participa
pas le partout là qui veulent enfin je
pense à laval dans région de montréal
c'est fascinant de voir ce qui va
arriver mais j'ai une question pour vous
plus globalement de quoi pensez-vous que
les québécois veulent entendre parler
dans cette campagne électorale si facile
on a l'impression qu'au départ sur la
ligne de départ on veut entendre parler
d'inflation en fait de deux coups de la
vie de la façon dont le gouvernement
peut nous aider ou les partis politiques
peuvent nous aider pour faire face à
l'augmentation du coût de la vie il ya
une surenchère même la campagne
électorale n'est pas encore commencé
qu'il ya déjà une surenchère monsieur
legault à paris de son chèque de 5000 un
chèque qui pourrait envoyer peut-être de
500 $ d'ici noël en plus de baisses
d'impôts loeb pendant le prochain mandat
s'il est élu alors que d'autres parties
parlent de baisses d'impôts notamment le
parti libéral donc il ya un appétit je
pense au départ pour cet enjeu love qui
veut pas dire que ce sera l'enjeu qui va
dominer l'ensemble de la compagnie kam
et disons que à 48 heures du
déclenchement au moins de 48 heures
déclenchement dans l'impression que
c'est celui qui se profile le plus à
l'horizon christian
moi je suis d'accord avec sébastien que
l'inflation en fait c'est un très
important c'est à dire si jamais comment
ça se déroule une campagne électorale
c'est ce qui fait les trains de la
politique là on sait pas encore comment
ça se termine moi j'espère qu'on attend
les français voient dans ce cas là je
vois vraiment toujours revenir sur le
français parce que les 5 6 2 en 2
non mais
c'est dramatique et là ça va continuer
et moi j'espère que les chefs de parti
la chef de parti mon roman est harcelé
qu'est ce que vous proposez complètement
pour le français pour qu'on sorte des
lamentations parce qu'on est un bon dans
les lamentations de québec donc j'ai
fini mon petit pitch si vous permettez
mais pour le reste ce que je comprends
ce qui m'intéresse c'est que presque des
partis qui vont performer mieux qu'on
pense prenez par exemple les rituels le
pq aussi est sculpté qui vaut profiter
peut-être 10 des bosses sur le ce procès
ça finit rarement comme ça a commencé et
puis c'est sûr qu'au départ legault
semble voguer vers une victoire certaine
mais pas arriver des choses et il va
arriver des chemins l'inflation s'est
préparé il aussi le peu que je voudrais
souligner c'est que on est chanceux les
québécois parce qu'une et sécurité mais
quand on se compare à l' angoisse qui
est en train de monter en europe après
en france en angleterre legault en
profite d'une insécurité mai et qui pour
une fois sont pas dans le drame donc
legault peu avant l'heure du bon père de
famille on lui reproche pas trop sévères
a très bien emilie qu'est ce que vous
savez qu est ce que vous sentez qu'est
ce que vous vous croyez qu'on va se
diriger dans l'est dans les débats dans
les premières semaines
je pense que françois legault discuter
et puis les bonnes notes de ce qui s'est
passé avec son bon ami doc word en
ontario ça faisait une campagne où il y
avait un premier ministre qui est parti
loin d'avant ce qui a dit au grand chose
durant la campagne
les thèmes très généraux
concentre déjà dans les annonces que la
caq de lavaur qui sont avec des
personnes des citoyens ordinaires où on
parle en fait peu de contenu politique
ou être je pense que le conte le slogan
continueront et déjà 1 200 sans cela
je m'attends à ce que françois goût
puisqu'il est déjà en elle souhaite
avoir provoquant pagny se passe le moins
de choses possibles on met le moins
d'idées de l'avoir qui se sait de débat
parce que si les choses continuent comme
ça il est déjà en bonne voie de se faire
réélire avec une forte majorité donc la
varde l'intérêt de françois legault en
fait d'abord une campagne le plus
tranquille possible c'est ce qui me mène
vers la victoire dans sa prestance mais
mais le québec n'est pas l'ontario comme
théâtre politique qui peut-être que
c'est plus difficile d'avoir une
campagne entière au québec sans qu'il y
ait des surprises ou et les ontariens
sont pas beaucoup aller voter en passant
s'il y avait en avant un taux si le taux
de participation québec était aussi bas
que celui de l'ontario la prochaine fois
toutes les lumières rouges eux seront
allumées sébastien
oui à surveiller le taux de
participation un des dangers pour la
cohésion de nos québec au départ c'est
que les gens aient pas voter en disant
il va passer tellement fort qu'on n'a
pas besoin d'aller voter ou même qui se
disent on va voter pour d'autres partis
pour contre balancer le poids de la
coalition décoller
utilise même je trouve
surveiller duhaime parce que son slogan
sur la liberté très très fort il
incarnait quand même une pousse son
gouvernement si ils s'enrichissent pas
trop dans un conservatisme à
l'américaine et si ce qui semble faire
et je pense que nous avons eu une nuit
c'est quelqu'un surveille et même le pq
le pq peut profiter de la bonne eau elle
mange voilà l'idée avec une obsession
pour le français
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on va sur qu'on
parlait très régulièrement durant cette
campagne électorale emilie aussi
christian sébastien bovet merci beaucoup
ses passions